Petty mit der Kamera zu folgen ist keine
leichte
Aufgabe voller Energie wuselt sie durch
die
Menge als freiwillige unterstützt sie
den Präsidentschaftskandidaten der
KMT es ist der Kandidat der dem
chinesischen Festland am freundlichsten
gegenüber
[Musik]
steht die 46-Jährige ist in China
geboren mit einem Taiwanesen verheiratet
und wünscht sich die guten alten Zeiten
zurück damals liefen der wirtschaftliche
und kulturelle Austausch zwischen beiden
Seiten reibungslos auch jetzt würde das
die Wirtschaft ankurbeln das Leben auf
dem Festland und auf Taiwan besser
machen sie wünscht sich dass Festland
China und die demokratische Insel wieder
näher zusammenrücken aber ihre
unterschiedlichen politischen Systeme
behalten hier kritisieren sie dass es
seit 8 Jahren keine offiziellen Kontakte
gibt sie beobachten die militärischen
drohebärden des mächtigen Nachbarn der
Taiwan als Teil seines Staatsgebiets
betrachtet ihre Lösung mehr Kontakt
nicht
weniger ich bin jetzt sehr aufgeregt
weil wir sehen dass die KMT Partei so
viele Unterstützer hat die alle das
Gleiche wollen die Menschen wollen
Veränderung das sieht josephen ganz
anders er unterstützt die
Regierungspartei die Taiwans
Eigenständigkeit betont und in den
Umfragen vorne liegt vier Stunden pro
Tag sitzt er hier jeden Tag und guckt
das was Chinas Staatsführung Nachrichten
nennt was mehr eine strengkrollierte
Propagandashow
ist joseph ist sowas wie ein Detektiv
ein digitaler
Spurensucher jede Info die er über
Chinas Militär finden kann sammelt der
24-Jährige
dieser Ort z.B hier gibt's eine
Straße einen
Strommast ein und aus dann gucke ich wo
das sein
könnte jedes Detail zählt dieser blaue
Schimmer stammt von der Leuchtschrift
einer Klinik hat J
rausgefunden manchmal dauert es Stunden
oder Tage bis er den richtigen Ort hat
Infos auf seiner öffentlich zugänglichen
Karte ergänzen
kann angefangen hat er als vor ein paar
Jahren Chinas Militär mal wieder in
Taiwans Luftraum eindrang er wollte
wissen woher die Jets kamen und hatte
viel Zeit es
herauszufinden denn das Abschlusskonzert
seines Musikstudiums war gerade wegen
Corona abgesagt worden die Plakate waren
schon
[Musik]
gedruckt Musik das ist die zweite
Leidenschaft des
militärfans es ist seltsam für ihn jeden
Tag Chinas Propaganda im Fernsehen zu
sehen gerade erst sprach Staats und
parteichf Jen Ping in seiner
Neujahrsrede mal wieder von der
historisch unvermeidbaren
wiervereinigung ich lebe in einem
anderen Land mit anderer politischer
Philosophie anderer Ideologie also war
es anfangs etwas komisch aber nachdem
ich es über einen längeren Zeitraum ut
hatte war es okay man muss es als Studie
betrachten warum benutzen sie
ausgerechnet diese Worte welche
Botschaft wollen sie
senden Jackie unterstützt den dritten
Präsidentschaftskandidaten bevor er uns
das erzählt sollen wir uns in seinem
Hostel ganz zu Hause fühlen du kannst
die Tasse wählen die dir am besten
gefällt welche magst du denn am liebsten
diese hier die
bunte okay dann nehme ich die hier das
Grün passt do gut zu
dir der 31-Jährige ist der Manager hier
doch oft macht er auch alles andere denn
Personal zu finden ist schwierig die
Löhne sind niedrig es gibt wenig
Aufstiegschancen er wünscht sich dass
mit besseren Beziehungen zum Festland
auch Fachkräfte von China nach Taiwan
kommen mit der Sprache und allem mit
Ausländern zu sprechen ist nie einfach
wie mit
Chinesen sie wären uns hier sehr
willkommen Taiwan und China haben viele
kulturelle Gemeinsamkeiten und es wäre
gut
zusammenzuarbeiten er ist die alte
Diskussion Leid schon seit seiner Jugend
sei immer wieder von Chinas Plan die
Rede Taiwan
einzunehmen passiert ist das bis heute
nicht wir haben eigene Pässe eine eigene
Armee sind ein souveränes unabhängiges
Land es gibt keinen Grund Taiwans
Unabhängigkeit zu betonen und damit noch
mehr Streit zu
verursachen er hofft dass sein Kandidat
sich um das Problem kümmert dass ihn und
viele junge Leute auf Taiwan viel mehr
umtreibt die hohen
Immobilienpreise deshalb ist er nach
hinchu gezogen 80 km von der Hauptstadt
entfernt hier lebt er mit seiner Familie
im Haus der Schwiegereltern
mietfrei
meine Kinder sollen sich in Zukunft ein
Haus leisten können wenn sie hart
arbeiten im Gegensatz zu meiner
Generation die sich das nicht leisten
kann egal wie hart wir
arbeiten wir treffen Petty wieder die
steht auch am Tag nach der
Wahlkampfveranstaltung keine Sekunde
still viele Jahre hat sie mit ihrer
Familie auf dem chinesischen Festland
gelebt weil ihre Kinder nun auf Taiwan
studieren ist sie zurü
[Musik]
üommen die Menschen wollen Frieden und
Austausch das ist es was uns am Herzen
liegt wenn die Leute vom Festland nach
Taiwan reisen können Kurbeln sie den
Tourismus hier an das wäre sehr
[Musik]
gut was PY Joseph und Jackie
gleichermaßen hoffen dass egal welcher
Kandidat der nächste Präsident wird es
friedlich bleibt auf
Taiwan